je n'ai pas la nostalgie d'un exil qui
me libère d'une patrie d'une patrie qui
pèse sur mon souffle
colette lit en français ce poème
intitulé icilaba dallas mohammad la
réalisatrice et poétesse a fui la syrie
pour venir en france en 2012
aujourd'hui elle participe avec diane et
alassane à cette balade des libertés
organisée et initié par l'antenne locale
d'amnesty international à saint quentin
en yvelines en est mais pour ça pour
communiquer pour vivre en simple pour
dialoguer pour avoir la profondeur c'est
à dire l'autre c'est notre miroir diane
hakizimana venus également témoigné
partage elle aussi son vécu journaliste
au burundi elle est partie de son pays
en 2014 pour ne plus y retourner
laissant sa famille derrière elle
reporter à la radio elle dénonçait la
dictature elle risque la mort si elle
retourne un jour dans son pays d'origine
ça fait toujours du bien de partager ce
qu'on a vécu ce qu'on vit avec les
autres germoir c'est
c'est beaucoup quand partage c'est là
aussi on arrive à être enrichi à un
moment une initiative qui dure depuis
déjà 10 ans et permet de relayer les
campagnes message d'amnesty
international on parle de cette question
des réfugiés depuis déjà 2012 loin et
puis on sait que c'est un combat de
longue haleine qu'il faut faire prendre
conscience aux gens que les réfugiés
sont des gens comme nous et puis faire
prendre conscience à nos politiques
qu'il faut qu'on qu'on accepte de les
recevoir dans des bonnes conditions
ce moment d'échangé ouvert à tous sera
reconduit l'année prochaine
le 2 juillet